هذه الوحوش الطائره من يقدر على ترويضها
يملك السماء ويضمن النصر لجيش بلاده
طائرات مقاتله مزوده باحدث التقنيات واعتى
الصواريخ وقد تصل تكلفه الواحده منها
لمئات ملايين الدولارات لكن كلمه السر
تبقى بمن يقودها
[موسيقى]
منذ قرون عده تتنافس اقوى جيوش العالم
وتنفق مئات مليارات الدولارات لتطوير
طرازات مختلفه من الطائرات المقاتله
لكنها ورغم كل ذلك تبقى بلا جدوى دون طيار
يتمتع بقدرات خارقه
فهناك في السماء وبسرعه تفوق سرعه الصوت
لا مجال للخطا ابدا مهما كان صغيرا ومن
يقود هذه الكتله الطائره من الاسلحه
والتقنيات لابد ان يكون شخصا غير عادي
سلاح الجو الامريكي يطبق برامج مكثفه قد
تستمر لسنوات وتدريبات في غايه الصرامه
لطياره قبل ان يصبحوا مؤهلين بشكل كامل
لقياده احدى الطائرات الحربيه
فمثلا هذه طائره اي عشره كلفه تدريب
قائدها تتجاوز السبعه ملايين دولار
وطائره بي اثنان تبلغ كلفه تدريب قائدها
نحو 12 مليون دولار
اما هذا الوحش وهو المقاتله اف 22
فتصل تكلفه تدريب طيارها الى نحو 13 مليون
دولار قبل ان يصبح مؤهلا للقصف والمناوره
والقتال
تختلف تكلفه تدريب الطيارين اختلافا كبيرا
بناء على نوع الطائره فعلى سبيل المثال
يكلف تدريب طيار مقاتله اف 22
حوالي عشره اضعاف تكلفه تدريب الطيار على
قياده طائره الشحن العسكريه سي 17
تلك المبالغ هي لتدريب طيار مؤهل واحد فقط
فما بالكم بتكلفه تدريب اسراب من الطائرات
المقاتله في جيوش العالم
يوجد في العالم اكثر من 53 الف طائرات
مقاتله نشطه حاليا ثلاث دول فقط تمتلك 40%
منها امريكا وحدها تشغل ما يمثل 25% من
الحصه العالميه لهذه الطائرات
بامتلاكها اكبر اسطول عسكري جوي في العالم
يتكون من 13 الفا ومئتين وسته واربعين
طائره
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه موازين القوات
تغيرت الجيوش طورت من منظوماتها الدفاعيه
والهجوميه لكن من اساسيات التكتيكات
العسكريه ان من يملك السماء يضمن التفوق
لذا تبقى الطائرات المقاتله العنصر الحاسم
في اي معركه والعنصر الاهم هو كفاءه
طيارها وخبراتهم